With the amount of research that must be done
within the SCP Foundation, including tests
on all the various anomalies currently in
containment, it is only natural for Foundation
staff to include some of the greatest scientific
minds in the multiverse.
Minds such as Dr. Jack Bright, who began his
career as human with only two outstanding
qualities: his keen intellect and his absurdly
poor luck.
The latter of which eventually resulted in
his temporary demise and resurrection into
the technically disembodied consciousness
we know and love today.
Though having his great mind transferred into
the anomalous medallion SCP-963 has only made
him more eccentric with time, Dr. Bright might
be the poster child for the ideal foundation
researcher: an out of the box thinker with
a flexible relationship to his own mortality
and morality.
Of course, Bright isn’t the only man of
science out there who could be classified
as an anomaly.
As a matter of fact, one particular man on
the Foundation’s radar could easily claim
such a status and then go beyond it with his
nasty habit of bragging about his accomplishments.
That man is the self-proclaimed smartest being
in the universe: Rick Sanchez.
Seemingly the unemployed live-in grandfather
of the middle-class Smith family, Rick spends
his spare time traveling freely between outer
space and different dimensions, assisted by
his signature portal gun and a metric buttload
of other gadgets of Sanchez’s own design.
Rick Sanchez has been sought after by the
research team of SCP Foundation on three occasions
before.
Once, when the elderly scientist was scouted
for a job interview which he famously didn’t
take seriously.
According to one of the researchers present,
Sanchez would repeatedly belch in the middle
of his sentences and over the course of the
interview made several references to a supposed
“Cabin In The Woods.”
When asked to elaborate what he meant by those
remarks, Sanchez did not.
This insubordination - combined with his gas
and bad attitude - ultimately cost him the
job.
Several months later, the SCP Foundation would
discover that during the time that Sanchez
had been present for his interview, which
had taken place within Biological Containment
Site-103, the foul-tempered inventor had smuggled
several instances of SCP-2941 out of the facility
in what Sanchez himself would later describe
as “one of those bags of holding, you know,
from dungeons and dragons.”
As those familiar with the Foundation’s
records would know, instances of SCP-2941
can be extremely dangerous outside of containment
due to the anomalous produce’s potential
for explosive growth in conditions of increased
morale.
It was a stroke of good fortune that when
Mobile Task Force Theta 4 A.K.A.
The Gardeners finally caught up with Sanchez
at his earthly home that all instances of
SCP-2941 were recorded as having lower morale
levels than had ever been recorded.
According to Sanchez, he had injected the
instances with a specialized serum capable
of inducing a state of permanent depression
in anything with a conscious mind.
To quote Sanchez, “I fixed your dumb fruit
problem.
You’re welcome.”
While both of the previous occasions were
mostly unpleasant for any SCP Foundation staff
involved and better left forgotten, it was
the third encounter with Rick Sanchez where
the man went from a minor annoyance to a being
capable of threatening the Foundation’s
very existence.
It all started, as is often enough the case
when misfortune arises, when Dr. Bright got
one of his infamous out-of-the-box ideas.
The immortal researcher was reviewing the
data from the SCP-2941 case, and realized
that it might be possible for the Foundation
to use Sanchez to neutralize other – more
overtly hostile – anomalies.
Specifically, SCP-682 - the hard to destroy
reptile.
While everything that the Foundation had previously
thrown at SCP-682 had done little more than
increase its aggression, Dr. Bright imagined
that a man as unpredictable as Rick Sanchez
might have an invention that could at least
weaken the reptile or otherwise reduce its
capacity to do harm.
Of course, the most delicate part of this
proposed solution was securing the compliance
of Rick Sanchez in the first place.
While many researchers would rather deal with
SCP-682 in its current state, rather than
risk the involvement of such an unstable individual,
Bright was surprisingly optimistic about his
chances to obtain Rick’s help.
Maybe it was the fact that Dr. Bright had
always thought of himself as something of
a loose cannon by the Foundation’s standards,
but he wasn’t intimidated by Sanchez’s
brand of chaotic shenanigans.
Also, because SCP-682 was one of the anomalies
that Dr. Bright was not permitted to make
contact with after the last incident, he felt
a sense of duty to contribute to the effort
of neutralizing it.
If he could help solve one of the Foundation’s
biggest problems to date - even in an indirect
way - Bright would be able to enjoy an immense
sense of accomplishment and purpose in his
eternal life.
Inspired by his own questionable genius, Dr.
Bright set about preparing for his confrontation
with Rick Sanchez.
After all, Bright would be marching straight
into the mad scientist’s private fortress
- the Smith household - and if possible, he
would want to be at least twice as prepared
as Sanchez was.
Dr. Bright’s first priority was selecting
an anomalous weapon that he could brandish
in case the diplomatic approach was a failure.
After considering his vast array of options,
Bright eventually settled on SCP-3108 - also
known as The Nerfing Gun.
While Sanchez was known to surprise both his
friends and foes by deploying never-before-seen
gizmos in the heat of the moment, Dr. Bright
could rest assured that with the Nerfing Gun
as his sidearm, any invention that Rick brought
to the table would instantly become less effective
after a few well-placed shots.
Next, was the matter of keeping up with Rick
Sanchez in case the scientist decided to escape
from the conversation by opening a portal
to one of the other infinite realities he
had access to.
While anomalies that could cross dimensions
were far from unheard of at the Foundation,
Bright’s options for consistent and reliable
interdimensional transportation were severely
limited.
Jack was starting to realize that there was
a reason why the formula for Rick’s portal
fluid was so highly in-demand in the greater
multiverse.
Whether or not he really was the smartest
being in the universe, it was clear that Rick
Sanchez had one advantage over ninety percent
of the anomalies on record: he had an unparalleled
knack for running away.
Initially, Dr. Bright was planning to bluff
the scientist by arriving at his doorstep
with SCP-507 - the Reluctant Dimensional Traveler.
The hapless and otherwise ordinary young man
did possess the potential to follow Rick into
any dimension that the portal gun could reach,
though because he had no control over when
or where his body would be transported, the
prospect of having him assist Dr. Bright in
chasing Rick was a massive gamble.
SCP-507 also didn’t knowingly have the ability
to bring along other individuals in his unplanned
leaps through reality, and with the fact that
Dr. Bright had notoriously bad luck - the
chances of winding up in the blender dimension
would be much higher than usual even if a
shared dimension hop were possible.
Dr. Bright thought to himself that maybe Sanchez
would know how to stabilize SCP-507’s relationship
with spacetime.
Then he laughed to himself in quiet frustration.
Was he already turning to Rick for the answers
to other anomalous problems when he hadn’t
even met with him yet.
His concern was still with neutralizing SCP-682,
but somehow even that felt dimensions away
now.
Feeling a bit depressed, Dr. Bright was all
but ready to throw in the towel when an unexpected
volunteer expressed interest in Dr. Bright’s
plan.
It was none other than SCP-343 - God himself.
God said to Dr. Bright that he had been aware
of Rick Sanchez prior to his confinement at
the Foundation, and knew the man to be lacking
in all forms of humility.
He said that even when it came to the heavy
responsibilities of creation, Rick had a tendency
to view his own suffering in the same way
he viewed his supposed better qualities: as
yet another competition he was winning.
To that end, SCP-343 believed that it was
important that he visit Sanchez alongside
Bright, in the hopes that a chance interaction
with the alleged creator of the universe might
humble the man if nothing else.
More crucially, SCP-343 was able to do the
very thing that Dr. Bright required for this
plan to work: free and unrestricted interdimensional
travel.
SCP-343 warned Dr. Bright that the use of
such powers may alarm his so-called next-door
neighbors in the other realities, but he also
assured the immortal researcher that the beings
that most closely resemble 343 himself tend
to be generally reasonable.
Dr. Bright was a bit confused by that explanation,
but he was grateful to have such a powerful
and benevolent anomaly at his side if he was
to face Rick Sanchez.
With SCP-3108 in his hand and SCP-343 ready
and willing to assist should the situation
turn sour, Dr. Bright decided that his preparations
were complete.
He made his way to the Smith Household, where
Rick would be awaiting him.
Fortunately, the man wasn’t that hard to
find.
Probably because he wasn’t expecting company
that day.
When Bright arrived at the house, the door
to the garage was already wide-open.
Inside was Rick Sanchez tinkering with some
unknown piece of futuristic technology.
Dr. Bright knew better than to lead with any
questions about Rick’s new device, as the
response would probably be some kind of snarky
non-answer.
Instead, he chose to approach casually with
SCP-3108 behind his back.
At this time, SCP-343 had chosen to make himself
invisible, vowing to interfere only if Dr.
Bright needed to pursue Sanchez through the
dimensions.
Before Dr. Bright had even made it all the
way up the driveway, Sanchez indicated that
he was aware of the researcher’s presence.
The rogue scientist didn’t even look up
from his work, and while Bright couldn’t
quite comprehend what had been said due to
an unexpected belch from Rick, he knew that
he had been insulted somehow.
Not one to be discouraged by mere words, Dr.
Bright introduced himself and explained that
he was from the SCP Foundation.
He reminded Rick of his history with the Foundation,
and politely asked if Rick was interested
in doing some pro-bono work for them.
To which, Rick snickered.
It was clear that being vague wasn’t helping
his case, so Bright asked again, this time
laying out in more detail the task that the
research team wanted Rick to perform.
Doing his best to avoid giving away any information
that might indirectly compromise the foundation,
Dr. Bright explained SCP-682 and its capabilities
in the hopes that Rick might agree to see
the creature out of a sense of scientific
curiosity.
Once again, Rick didn’t even look in Bright’s
direction before saying “It’s a big universe
and I’ve got better things to do than pick
a fight with some lizard.
If you want my advice, toss that thing out
with the garbage somewhere and forget about
it.
That way, it’s not your problem, and it’s
definitely not mine.”
Dr. Bright wasn’t sure how to respond at
first.
He had heard that Sanchez was unreasonable,
but he wasn’t expecting the man to suggest
that SCP-682 should be released from captivity.
The recklessness of such a concept was shocking
for a seasoned Foundation researcher, but
there was something else: Rick Sanchez didn’t
seem at all phased by the existence of 682.
The way that the man spoke made it sound like
even an indestructible monster was beneath
him.
Could it be possible that Sanchez had faced
far worse things before in his adventures
through the multiverse?
Or was he simply too apathetic to register
SCP-682 as a threat?
He could also be a fool.
Dr. Bright thought to himself, but he dismissed
that notion immediately.
If there was one thing the Foundation knew
for sure about Rick Sanchez, it was that the
man had to be some kind of genius - sane or
otherwise.
Dr. Bright was intrigued, and at that moment,
that feeling got the better of him.
He proceeded to explain the death toll that
SCP-682 was capable of: the inevitable loss
of life which occurred every time the reptile
broke free of containment.
Rick gave another dispassionate answer, “Again,
it sounds like your organization specializes
in taking things that would be better left
alone and making them into ‘you problems’.
If that’s what lets you sleep at night,
I’m not going to stop you, but you can’t
convince me that it’s a ‘me problem.’”
Dr. Bright was at a loss.
Surely, Rick Sanchez knew that the sacrifices
made to keep SCP-682 from escaping the foundation
were necessary to prevent innocent lives from
being stolen.
The entire point of keeping anomalies secured
and contained was to protect humanity from
beings like 682.
If there were a better way, especially regarding
one of the most deadly and malicious creatures
that the Foundation had ever come across,
naturally, any researcher would want to take
it.
And yet, here was Rick Sanchez, mocking everything
the foundation stood for.
Dr. Bright had to laugh because he finally
understood who and what the man he was dealing
with now really was.
As a former human turned immortal consciousness,
Dr. Bright had to reckon every day with the
question of how to spend the rest of his endless
existence.
There had been times since his mind was copied
into SCP-963 that Bright had been so consumed
with boredom, he questioned whether it was
meaningful to do anything at all with his
days.
After all, there would come a point in the
distant future where everything and everyone
he ever knew would be completely gone.
The entire world and most of the people and
anomalies within it wouldn’t last forever,
and he’d probably still be here long after
most everything else was gone.
Until the necklace his mind was bound to was
somehow destroyed, Dr. Bright would live on
indefinitely until everything in existence
turned to dust.
Because of this heightened awareness of eternity,
Dr. Bright had forgotten what it was like
to be on the other side of the nihilism he
felt daily: He had forgotten that everyone
else in the universe was afraid of meeting
their end.
Including Rick Sanchez.
That was why he couldn’t but laugh out loud
in front of that man.
He was laughing because, for all of Sanchez’s
intelligence, the man was powerless against
his own nihilistic apathy and the powerful
sense of worthlessness that came with it.
Sanchez reacted swiftly to Bright’s laughter,
craning his neck towards the SCP researcher
and asking “What was so funny?”
in a seemingly offended tone.
Dr. Bright simply responded, “Oh, nothing”
and added that coming here was a mistake.
It’s not as if Rick Sanchez was actually
capable of helping the Foundation deal with
SCP-682.
Dr. Bright made that remark with as much sarcasm
as he could muster, directly to Rick’s face.
Rick was quick to snap back at Bright with
the assertion that he could totally deal with
their lizard problem: he just didn’t feel
motivated to.
Just then, Rick’s grandson Morty Smith came
into the garage.
He was about to ask his grandfather for help
with him and his sister Summer’s homework
when he noticed Dr. Bright standing by.
Morty took one look at the medallion around
Dr. Bright’s neck and immediately became
excited from sudden recognition.
“Aww, geez, Rick, that’s Dr. Bright from
the SCP Foundation!”
Morty said, excitedly.
“Forget my homework!
Are we doing an SCP adventure today?”
Rick groaned in disbelief.
“No, we are not doing an SCP adventure.
Because I don’t respect them or their weird
obsession with imprisoning stuff, and neither
should you.”
He belched loudly and turned back to his work
desk, but Morty’s expression turned angry,
and it was clear that he wasn’t about to
leave.
“Typical, Rick.
There’s finally an adventure I want to do,
and you’re acting like it’s lame!
You know, a lot of people really enjoy SCPs!
There’s even this Youtube channel called
SCP Explained that makes these really good
videos that explain the lore and tell some
awesome stories,” Morty said, directly into
the camera.
“Woof.
Are you doing an ad for them right now, Morty?
That’s pretty shameless,” Rick replied.
Dr. Bright got the feeling that these two
could go on for a while, and he also started
to get the impression that he was being ignored.
He waited patiently for a lull in the banter,
but it didn’t seem to be happening anytime
soon.
Perhaps Dr. Bright could use this to his advantage.
Rick Sanchez’ portal gun was lying on the
garage’s workbench not too far away from
where Dr. Bright was standing.
One well-placed shot from SCP-3108 could be
sufficient to cut off Sanchez’ means of
escape.
All Dr. Bright had to do was line up the shot
and fire while Sanchez was distracted.
Seeing just such an opportunity, Dr. Bright
moved the nerfing gun into position, but unfortunately
for him, Morty - the resident SCP expert of
the Smith family, as he was an avid subscriber
and watcher of SCP Explained - noticed what
he was holding and identified it immediately.
“Careful, Rick!
Dr. Bright brought SCP-3108 with him!”
Morty shouted.
Rick responded, “Which one is that again?
Is that the bird that causes separation anxiety?”
“No, that’s 3103!
3108 is–”
Dr. Bright fired SCP-3108 before Morty could
finish his sentence, but the boy was more
capable than Bright could have anticipated.
Sanchez’s grandson dove recklessly into
the path of the projectile, shielding the
portal gun with his body and immediately suffering
the anomalous effects of the nerfing gun:
devolving into a neanderthal.
Rick looked at Morty, who was now a caveman,
and became immediately enraged.
And it was easy to understand why: nobody
uses Rick Sanchez’ grandson to test strange
new inventions except for Rick Sanchez himself.
Rick grabbed his portal gun from the workbench
and returned fire on Dr. Bright, creating
two portals on the fly – one behind Dr.
Bright and the other in the path of the researcher’s
second nerf round.
The projectile zoomed through one portal and
out the other to collide with the back of
Dr. Bright’s head.
Since his consciousness was contained inside
the medallion, Dr. Bright didn’t suffer
any mental changes as a result of being regressed
to a neanderthal, but the transformation did
grant him a newfound muscle mass and strength
only known to his primitive ancestors.
And he was about to need it.
Rick slammed a large cube onto the counter
that had a single large blue button on the
top, and as one must expect, pressed the button.
Dr. Bright had never seen this before, but
this was one of Rick Sanchez’s other most
prized inventions: the Meeseeks box.
The instant Sanchez pressed that button, an
unusual blue humanoid materialized into reality
from thin air.
“I’m Mr. Meeseeks!
Look at me!” said the humanoid, apparently
known as Mr. Meeseeks.
“Get rid of that guy!”
Rick ordered, and immediately Mr. Meeseeks
began sprinting towards the researcher with
single-minded determination.
Dr. Bright only had time to fire a single
shot from SCP-3108 before Mr. Meeseeks grabbed
him by the wrists and tried to wrestle the
nerfing pistol away.
It was a smart move on Bright’s part, because
the nerf round struck the Meeseeks box directly
- rendering it near useless as the exterior
turned red and the word “Kirkland” appeared
on the box’s side.
Annoyed, Rick pushed the Meeseeks box into
the trash.
While he could rest assured that he wouldn’t
have to contend with another Mr. Meeseeks,
it was taking all of Dr. Bright’s current
caveman strength to prevent the blue humanoid
from disarming him.
Desperate to gain some advantage over Sanchez
and his inventions, Dr. Bright called for
help from SCP-343, which Rick misinterpreted
as the researcher praying to be spared from
the mad genius’ wrath.
Sanchez was shocked when 343 became visible
and immediately appeared before Mr. Meeseeks.
“I release you from your quest for purpose,”
God said to Mr. Meeseeks, and a grin spread
over the humanoid’s face.
In the next moment, Mr. Meeseeks was gone,
returned to the void of nonexistence.
God then turned to Rick Sanchez with a stern
but fatherly look.
Rick was unamused.
“Oh, would you look at that?
Dr. Bright has a literal God on his side,”
Rick quipped sarcastically.
“What’s next, are you going to use the
power of anime on me?”
God wiggled his fingers and in a flash of
light… both Morty and Dr. Bright were restored
to their original human selves, or in Bright’s
case: human in appearance.
Morty sputtered, “Ahh, Rick, I’m freaking
out!
I just went through thousands of years of
human evolution.
I need to lie down.”
While Dr. Bright was grateful that his current
body felt more like himself again, he had
been counting on God to help him defeat Rick
Sanchez if things had gone bad.
And from the looks of it, the situation was
still pretty untenable.
That’s when Dr. Bright noticed that Rick
was no longer trying to fight back.
Instead, the rogue scientist was comforting
his grandson after the painful process of
two-way evolution.
Perhaps there was more to this man than his
devil-may-care antics and pessimistic outlook?
After giving Morty’s physical and mental
state the bare minimum level of consideration,
Rick turned to Dr. Bright and said:
“Hey, so, SCP guys, we’re going have to
do a rain check on this whole shebang until
Morty is feeling better.
I guess he really wanted to do an SCP adventure,
so I guess we’ll pencil you into our busy
Rick and Morty adventure schedule.
Just don’t bug us about it or make it a
big deal and we won’t either.”
Dr. Bright couldn’t help but smile.
He may not have gotten Rick to neutralize
SCP-382, but he just might have secured a
valuable asset for the foundation to call
upon in the future.
And that’s at least like half a win, right?
Now go check out “HILARIOUS List of Things
Dr. Bright is Not Allowed to Do!” and “SCP
Edition - Weirdest Things on Amazon - Dr Bright's
Great Idea!”
for more Dr. Bright adventures!
Wubba lubba dub dub!